today the Matt wall show one all ages
drag show was shut down in Tennessee
over the weekend but another one was
still held and it's the worst we've seen
yet also Italy elects its first female
prime minister but the media sadly
cannot celebrate because she has wrong
opinions it turns out plus the FBI sends
30 agents to raid a pro-life Act of his
home despite the fact that he broke no
laws at all the former mayor of Atlanta
who let BLM burn her City to the ground
has now repositioned herself as an
advocate of Law and Order and in our
daily cancellation a Tick-Tock feminist
laughs at 1950s dating advice but the
advice is way better than anything
you'll hear from a Tick-Tock feminist
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
with the Consumer Price Index increasing
yet again the stock market has been an
absolute turmoil what is the kurd
administration doing to quell The Surge
of inflation well they're spending more
taxpayer dollars of course don't bury
your head in the sand while your savings
deplete diversify into gold with Birch
gold today text Walsh to 98 98 98 and
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on protecting your savings with gold in
a tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs of 401ks
into precious metal IRAs with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers there's
no reason to not reach out to Birch gold
gold has always been your best hedge
against inflation if you have a 401k or
IRA that's underperforming all you got
to do is text Walsh to 98 98 98 and you
can convert that into an IRA in Precious
Metals right now again text Walston 98
98 98 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on diversifying into gold
tax-free take the necessary steps to
hedge against inflation today and
protect your hard earn money get your
free info kit by texting Walsh to 98 98
98 now
the Memphis Museum of Science and
History had a had planned to celebrate
Science and History this past weekend
with an all ages family friendly quote
unquote drag show and also dance party
the festivities were set to begin at
seven in the evening and then continue
until 11 at night there would be along
with the cross-dressers a full bar you
know people drinking drinking until they
have their fill of course to normal
non-groomer adults it's already wildly
inappropriate to invite small children
to a late night dance party with alcohol
and that would be true even if no drag
queen showed up I mean with the possible
exceptions of wedding receptions I
suppose but even then you know young
kids are going to go home before 11 at
night but maybe aside from those it's
hard to think of a scenario where it
would be acceptable to involve kids in
an event like this a dance party with
alcohol that goes to 11 at night
and why would you want to I mean what is
the non-creepy non-petophilic reason for
opening this up to children in fact
um I this is a question that um I've
been asking many of us have been asking
for for years now
I actually called the museum myself a
couple of weeks ago
and pose this question to them when I
first heard about this event they were
planning it's a simple one I mean why do
you want kids there
and also what does a drag dance party
have to do with science or history now
as to the latter question the woman on
the other end of the line who initially
told me that she could answer any
question I might have about the event
she said that that drag is it's a part
of the culture and thus it's a it's a
matter of History because it's part of
culture now I wasn't especially
persuaded by that reasoning but I was
more interested in getting an answer to
the second question why do you want kids
at the event and to that she kind of
stuttered and paused and responded and I
quote
is what she said
because it's an event
why do you want kids at the event well
because it's an event
yes but why are you involving kids
at that point she actually uh she said
that actually you know it turns out that
she's not the best person to answer my
questions and she'll have to have
someone call me back
but it doesn't seem that they ever came
up with an answer to the why do you want
kids their question at least not one
that they are willing to say out loud
and I know that based on what happened
this past Friday night which was
supposed to be the day of the event the
museum ended up shutting down the drag
dance party for children at the last
minute uh blaming the presence of
allegedly armed protesters there's a
very small group of people that the
media identified as quote unquote proud
boys who came and stood peacefully
outside of the museum and this has
prompted much handwringing from the very
same people who had absolutely nothing
to say a few weeks ago when a much
larger Battalion of masked and heavily
armed antifa showed up to a drag show in
Texas confronting a peaceful group of
protesters there now in that case there
was no problem at all but now it's a big
deal in any case the event was canceled
and the drag performers or would-be drag
performers that night anyway expressed
their frustration listen
I'm disappointed in Memphis I am I just
wish
I wish people were just more
knowledgeable and more
accepting I do uh particularly
disappointed I feel like when we do
things that cancel it it kind of
reinvigorates these groups to continue
the work that they're doing with
intimidating people the Memphis Museum
of Science and History hosted a summer
of Pride program celebrating the lgtbq
plus Community the drag show billed as
family friendly was supposed to be the
grand culmination Susan Gray and her
husband expressed their disapproval
displaying signs next to the American
flag on their car why does it bother you
when someone else brings their own child
to see this performance child abuse I
don't care who does it it's wrong why
are you telling people to leave when no
one asks you to tell people to leave
we're not telling people to leave we're
telling people to exit the parking lot
it wasn't our decision to shut the
museum down organizer Barbie weyer
heartbroken the show won't go on Angry
mosh and MPD didn't stand up to
protesters people there's an entire
exhibit in there that's about the
history of police removing queer people
from spaces of a country that does not
want us to exist of a culture that does
not want us to exist and so tonight
proves that we are still living as a
part of that history
you know it's obvious from the tone of
the questioning that the local NBC
affiliate has chosen a side they've
sided with the drag groomers but even so
they inadvertently provided a very
telling contrast because on the one hand
you had a normal middle-aged woman who
has taken the exceedingly rational
stance that child sexual abuse is
unacceptable
even if the parents are involved in fact
the parents involvement makes it worse
if anything
certainly not better
on the other hand you have a man in a
literal clown wig with Insane Clown
Posse face paint strutting around in a
woman's dress babbling that he's being
oppressed because he's not allowed to
dance for a bunch of kids at a science
museum
now it's up to each of us as individuals
to decide whose side we prefer to be on
here
but you notice that still none of the
people involved were able or willing to
engage with the one Central complaint
that the protesters have namely that the
event involves children okay nobody is
showing up to protest adult-only drag
shows those happen all the time in this
country no protesters footage from
adult-only drag shows never go viral
with people on the right outraged about
it
these uh female mocking Minstrel shows
have existed in this in this country for
decades and they were never a major
issue until they got the kids involved
now I personally think that all drag
shows are weird and ugly and bad and
degrading but even I wouldn't be talking
about them if they simply left the kids
out of it
is that too much to ask
I mean go ahead and dress up like some
kind of weird sexualized Muppet and
prance around on stage lip syncing to
Lady Gaga songs go ahead and do that
just do it out of sight where I don't
have to see it and most importantly kids
don't have to see it that's all we're
asking
and it proves to be too much
it was certainly too much for the drag
show over in Chattanooga this weekend as
Tennessee
continues unfortunately to be involved
in these kinds of issues and all of the
worst ways Robbie Starbuck provided
footage of this um all ages drag
spectacle that again happened on the
same weekend
and it's some of the most disturbing
that we've seen so we'll watch some of
this and I'll have to narrate it because
it's there's not a lot of audio but
let's play this clip
so you see there
dressed like the little mermaid
and a child is
[Music]
stroking his general area
[Music]
and then we've got another
okay here's another drag guy
and here's the move you always see the
up spreads his legs open for the kids
kids are standing there totally confused
oh there's a kid sitting at the bar
nothing wrong with that right
and this guy dressed like a fat Poison
Ivy from Batman walking around
and the kids are just the kids are not
into it they don't know why they're
there
look they walk away look the girl's
hiding behind her mom
all right it turns off
I mean that ended up being the most
telling moment in that in the clip is
that uh this guy is walking around the
kid hides behind her mom she does not
want to be there she's like who the hell
is this guy I don't want to talk to this
guy
so to recap
there is a man in a little mermaid
outfit
um who uh you know there's not even any
time to make any jokes about black
mermaids because uh the the more
relevant fact is that he's standing
there as a young child rubs his crotch
now obviously the child has no idea what
she's doing she's just a kid she sees
the sequence you know a little mermaid
outfit but he realizes what she's doing
and he makes no attempt to stop her just
stands her another man spreads his leg
for the legs for the children attendees
and then another one walks around
through the crowd slowly terrorizing
each child individually
now it's obvious when you watch this
kind of footage that these are not drag
events where kids just happen to be
attending
which would be bad enough
rather the whole point of the event is
to expose an indoctrinated kids and it's
not like there's any entertainment value
otherwise these are just pudgy guys who
can't sing or dance I can't do anything
just kind of like sauntering around
looking like creatures from Pan's
Labyrinth occasionally molesting a child
as they walk by
why though what's the point
nobody involved will explain why they
want the kids there why in fact they
structure the entire event around the
involvement of kids
that's because the answers are all
things they won't say out loud it's not
they don't have an answer is that they
won't say it
now we know of course at the main point
and the most Sinister is to sexualize
the kids Rob them of their innocence but
there's more to it even than that
these drag performances are gaudy and
ugly
and the left as we know hates Beauty and
they seek to condition us from the
youngest ages to idolize ugliness this
and it really it it works because this
is why many young people today go out of
their way to make themselves ugly
they've been brought up in a culture
that worships ugliness
and in the cult of ugliness drag is a
sacred ritual
and finally as always
the objective is to confuse
I mean that's why the Primary Emotion
you see on the faces of the kids
involved in in this sort of thing
involved against their will is confusion
they're just confused they don't
understand why they're there they don't
understand why these men are dressed
like this they don't understand any of
it
it is bewildering and disorienting and
confusing
that's how our culture wants them
because it's much easier to manipulate
and control a person when they're lost
in a fog of confusion
so ugly confused overly sexualized
this is our culture in a nutshell and
there are a few things uglier more
confused or sexualized than a drag show
so it's no wonder that the left is so
obsessed with them
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well Italy has elected its first female
prime minister which is reason to
celebrate you would think I mean
especially for the woke Among Us they
love it when glass ceilings are
shattered and this is a glass ceiling
it's a first female prime minister
this is what this so we can celebrate
can't we can't we well no we can't it
turns out because there are
qualifications there are always
qualifications that's why it's never
quite so simple as to say we talk about
identity Politics on the left and we
might say that well they you know they
hate straight white men but uh they and
they favor everybody else and I I sort
of wish it was that simple I mean I that
still wouldn't be good especially as a
straight white man myself but um it's
it's actually not that simple and at
least that would be in some strange way
as sort of a consistent ethic like uh
well straight white men are the villains
and everyone else is the hero and like
so there's some consistency there
it's not true it's not good but it's
consistency
um but there there is no consistency in
this case because yes they supposedly
they they pretend anyway to Champion
women and so-called marginalized groups
and all the rest of it but that's only
if
the people in those allegedly
marginalized groups
um
submit and surrender
ideologically
okay if they conform themselves
ideologically then they will be
championed but if not then not only are
they villains also but they're the worst
villains of all because along with being
villains are also traitors
because you know if you're a woman then
as far as the less concerned you owe
them Your Allegiance you are supposed to
have whatever opinions they assign to
you and if you don't then you've you've
betrayed them
you're a class Trader
um a traitor to your sex even though
they can't Define what that sex even is
so Italy's next prime minister it turns
out uh Georgia Maloney
she doesn't fit the qualifications
because she's on the right
and since she's on the right
her democratic election her selection by
the people of Italy who chose her this
is actually turns out a fascist takeover
it's uh in with with of course it in in
a a it's a fascist takeover that Harkens
back to events in history that they were
that the media is very quick to connect
those dots so I just want you to watch
this report from CBS and it's it is uh I
mean it's
it's kind of breathtaking
just how there's no attempt at all to
even pretend to be objective in how
they're reporting this
not even going to pretend let's watch
this
voters in Italy tomorrow appear poised
to make a hard right turn the woman
expected to become Prime Minister leads
a party with roots in neo-fascism Chris
lipsay is in Rome
Italy is revered for its history
reflected in palazzos and ruins and
statues but not all of that history is
beautiful and many fear that one
particularly ugly chapter could soon
repeat itself
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
Mussolini's historic march on Rome
plunging the country into two decades of
dictatorship an alliance with Hitler and
a second world war
today his fascist party is gone but many
say she is carrying the torch Georgia
Maloney leader of the brothers of Italy
what was once a fringe party has
ballooned into the biggest in the
country and it's now poised to lead the
most hard-right government since World
War II
fundamental problem in Italy is becoming
legal immigration too many immigrants to
protect the traditional family a family
composed by Mom and songs Italy's
conservative Superstar remains fiercely
opposed to adoptions and surrogacy for
same-sex couples the fiery 45 year old
is comfortable with some of the
Hallmarks of Italian fascism like this
and that's clearly a post-fascist party
um with a post-fascist agenda
umatelli is a political scientist at
roams American University
it has the
symbol of
the grave of Mussolini the same flame is
on Mussolini's grave yes now it's a
historic election also because Georgia
Maloney would be Italy's first ever
female prime minister an important glass
ceiling but one that's been overshadowed
by her politics Chris livesay CBS News
Rome I was just waiting for that at the
end I want to see if they at least
mentioned it and then finally at the end
oh yeah yeah first female prime minister
but the other thing that we would I mean
we would be tripping over ourselves in
in adulation you know if not for the
fact that it's overshadowed by politics
well who's chosen to make it overshot
who decided that why is it overshadowed
by politics well you've decided that in
the media it's overshadowed by your
politics not hers
now in some ways I am
um the perfect candidate for this
you know propaganda from
the media because I like many Americans
I imagine I don't know anything about
Georgia
Maloney I've never heard of her until
this past weekend I don't follow Italian
politics at all I confess to you
um so never heard of her
and so that means that I'm like a blank
site going in so the media they can they
and this is what they're counting on
most of us we don't follow we don't
follow Italian politics a lot of people
in this country don't even really follow
American politics so forget about
politics overseas and so they're
counting on what we're blank slates and
they could just tell us whatever they
want about her and we'll believe it
and the thing is that that's true like
I'm okay I'm I'm listening I have an
open mind what's what's the media what
case can the media make against her and
um just based on what they're telling
I'm like taking their word for it
actually
and what they tell me
is that Georgia Maloney
uh believes in protecting the nuclear
family
believes in protecting her borders
and the motto that she professes is God
Fatherland and family so God country
family
so they're making their case against her
this is the worst they could find we can
we can only assume if there was
something worse they'd tell us
if there were some darker skeletons
buried in the closet that they knew
about they would present those to us I
imagine
so this is the worst they could do and I
hear that and I think wow she sounds
great
now already I'm posed to like her
because our media hates her that's you
know that doesn't work this way 100 of
the time probably about 95 percent of
the time well maybe 99. probably 99 of
the time if the media tells you to hate
someone it means that you should
actually like them means that they're
great there there might be the one
percent of time when
inadvertently you know the media hates
someone who's actually worthy of our uh
of our loathing
I can't even think of a recent example
of that but maybe it's happened
so already I'm you know I'm I'm I'm
poised to uh
to like this woman and then and then
that's what they tell us well she's
she's a a fan of the nuclear family and
of borders
and of Faith sounds fantastic
and then I saw this so there's this
speech that she gave I think it's a
couple years ago
um
a speech that you gave that's making the
rounds online and I'll play it for you
obviously you won't be able unless you
speak Italian I can be able to
understand this so I'll have to I'll
have to translate for you based on the
subtitles I was tempted to attempt a uh
bad Italian accent while I read the
subtitles but I won't do that because
actually the message I don't want the
message to get lost in my bad accent so
let's go ahead and play this
is this is about what we are doing here
today
why is the family an enemy why is the
family so frightening
there's a single answer to all these
questions
because it defines us because it is our
identity because everything that defines
us is now an enemy
for those who would like us to no longer
have an identity
and to Simply Be Perfect consumer slaves
and so they attacked national identity
they attack religious identity attack
gender identity they attack family
identity
I can't Define myself as Italian
Christian woman mother
when I no longer have an identity or
roots
then I will be the perfect Slave at the
mercy of financial speculation
the perfect consumer
this is a great speech I wish we could
actually understand what you were saying
a lot better than what I'm doing that's
the reason why
that's why we Inspire so much fear
that's why this event inspires so much
fear okay
that is a speech that I wish a
republican politician would give I think
we have a few that would maybe get close
to that
but she's really getting to the roots of
it
and this is something that we uh talk
about in this show quite a bit you know
the this this uh
concept of identity
and we we hear about identity all the
time on the left they're seemingly
obsessed with it
but really what they're trying to do is
deprive us of identity so there this is
the point that she's making and and
she's right this is why they fear her
this is why they hate her
because you know if you're on the right
if you're a conservative at all of
course the media is going to hate you
but
um it's one thing to just sort of be on
the right and you can you can parrot
some of the lines you hear from other
conservatives and you know some of the
talking points and all of that and
that's mostly what you get from
conservatives in this country
they know the talking points they know
what lines to say to get Applause from
certain you know from certain audiences
um
but if you can show that you actually
understand what the left is doing and
why they're doing it do you really
understand their agenda
you can get a little bit beneath the
surface
well if you demonstrate that then you're
really a threat to them
because now you're giving away the trade
secrets and they can't have that
and from the little I know about this
woman just based on that speech alone
I can tell what that's that's all I need
to know
because this is the project on the left
it is to deprive us of identity to take
identity away
and how they do it they do that bias she
says like if first of all severing you
from all of the things
all of the outward
systems and institutions and structures
that give you identity
your family your faith your country
your bloodline your ancestors
take all that away
you know take out a a chainsaw and just
cut you away from all of that
and it's a it's you know it's a it's a a
bloody surgery for most people
sever you from that and just kind of
leave you uh
floating in The Ether
attached to nothing not grounded in
anything
but then even that's not enough because
after they've done that that's been the
project of the left for decades now
is to turn you against your own family
turn you against your country turn you
against your faith have you abandoned
your faith entirely
so they do that
that's not enough now
there's the next step is to go is to go
is to go into your mind
and to take away your sense of self
and this is where all the gender
ideology stuff comes into play
we talked about in the opening it's it's
about confusion they want you confused
they do this to kids at very young ages
this is why they send them to the drag
shows
make you confused take away your sense
of identity your sense of self
and then uh and then you're just you're
a perfect sort of vessel and vassal
at that point
all right so looks like Italy's got
their getting their act together
politically at least maybe we could
follow suit let's check in with a uh
another news report it's a local news
report here in Nashville about my expose
on Vanderbilt now never mind that in
this report just like in many other
media reports about the Vanderbilt thing
they call me they misgender Me by
calling me a conservative blogger I
haven't blogged like in like I I don't
know six or seven years but I'm not
gonna split hairs
um they do interview a local trans
activist who's who's uh very upset
she's very upset at me and any of the
rest of us who want to stop people from
mutilating kids
and uh he rather he's very upset I
should say at me and the rest of us
let's listen to Why
folks like me aren't monstrous these
children
no child is monstrous right but members
of the transgender Community like Darren
Johnson say this would do much more harm
than good the real danger is when that
type of care is taken away she says she
might not still be sitting here if it
wasn't for the gender affirming care she
received at Vanderbilt University
Medical Center and hates the thought
that minors might be stripped of those
options places like Vanderbilt are few
and far between Johnson says despite how
the transgender Clinic was characterized
she found Vanderbilt to be ethical and
thoughtful every step of the way there
are age appropriate
limits on what type of treatments are
even discussed or offered which is why
she's worried about what may happen next
on Capitol Hill it wouldn't just be a
shame if that went away it would make
her make for poorer families it would
make for poorer communities
Chris Davis NewsChannel 5.
representative Lambert tells NewsChannel
5 he plans to introduce legislation
regarding Vanderbilt's Clinic next
January when the new legislative session
begins okay so first of all he says this
is the gaslighting you always get
uh no no child is monstrous
they're they're treating children like
Monsters no no that's not it's not the
children that we're saying Are Monsters
um we're saying that we're saying the
opposite actually
their children are not Frankenstein
monsters that you can chop into pieces
and put other pieces on no children are
they are they are human beings they are
whole human beings
with dignity and that's how they should
be treated
and when you drug them and uh you cut
them you cut pieces of them off
you are along with with so many other
things depriving them of you you are of
that dignity or you're desecrating
that human dignity that they have
and you're doing it at an age when they
cannot possibly consent to it
and we hear also that uh
well we end up with poorer families I
don't know exactly what that means the
the state of the family
so the trans activists now they're
they're Defenders of the family unit
and the way that you defend the family
unit is to mutilate kids
but you notice and I've I've seen many
of these local news reports where they
they're doing the best they can to bring
in trans activists bringing a doctor
bring in someone
who will explain why you know our uh
efforts to stop this from happening kids
who will explain why that's a horrible
thing
and this is the best they can do
and you notice that none of them have
actually offered a
clear coherent defense
of what the hospital is doing to kids
instead all we hear is that well it's
age-appropriate it's an assertion
okay so to say that it's age appropriate
is an assertion
that's not a defense I understand that's
the assertion I understand that you
think it's age-appropriate
my question is how have you arrived to
that conclusion can you defend that
okay I do not see how it is age
appropriate
to chop the organs off of kids
can you explain how that could possibly
be age-appropriate how can a child
consent to that
they can't do it they can't even attempt
to do it then they won't
all right this is from the daily wire it
says FBI agents reportedly raided the
home of a pro-life activist in
Pennsylvania on Friday and arrested him
a group of between 25 and 30 FBI agents
raided the Bucks County Pennsylvania
home of pro-life activist Mark Houck
early Friday morning his family told
live site news Houck is the leader of a
non-profit group that provides sidewalk
counseling at abortion clinics in
Philadelphia
the arrest seemed to stem from a court
case that was dismissed by a federal
court in Philadelphia but was somehow
picked up by the Department of Justice
his family said
housewife Ryan Marie said the kids were
all just screaming it was all very scary
and traumatic Ryan Murray Houck told the
outlet that the group of agents in swat
gear arrived in 15 Vehicles outside the
family home at around 705 a.m it was on
Friday morning
so you've got about 30 FBI agents in
swat gear in 15 Vehicles rolling up to
this family's house
early in the morning the ages quickly
surrounded the house and began pounding
on the door demanding they open up halc
reportedly tried to get the agents to
calm down noting that his seven children
were scared but the agents kept shouting
they had big huge rifles pointed at Mark
and pointed at me and kind of pointed
throughout the house his wife said how
can his wife ask the agents why they
were there to which the agents allegedly
replied that they were there to arrest
him
his wife asked for a warrant but they
said that they were going to take him
whether they had a warrant or not Ryan
Murray halc recalled
she protested saying that what the
agents were doing was tantamounts of
kidnapping only then did they provide a
copy of the warrant shortly afterward
halc was barely taken out and put into
some into one of the vehicles
but the fbij agents quickly softened
quickly softened once they realized the
distress they'd inflicted on the family
housewife recounted once they realized
oh they didn't realize you know yeah
it's rolling up
seven o'clock in the morning on a Friday
you got a house there are seven kids in
there
you're all wearing SWAT gear there's 30
of you rolling up in 15 Vehicles they
had no idea that'd be distressing to the
kids no clue
um his wife says after they had taken
Mark and the kids were all screaming
that he was their best friend the agents
kind of softened a bit
I think they realized what was happening
or maybe they actually looked at the
warrant
now uh Hulk's wife is being very
generous and nice here uh which doesn't
surprise me because having been in the
pro-life world for a long time this is
why it's always so absurd to me it was
like and you don't have to be in the
pro-life world or be a pro-life activist
to realize how absurd is but especially
if you've been in that world and you
hear the way that uh pro-lifers are
demonized
like there are a bunch of you know the
the caricature of pro-lifers standing
around shouting and screaming and
they're you know really aggressive
dangerous scary people it is so
ludicrous
when you meet these people and almost
all of them are they're just like the
nicest people you'll meet in the world
the ones that are in the pro-life cause
so she's being very nice here even to
the FBI agents after they uh kidnapped
her husband she had a quote they look
pretty ashamed of what had just happened
according to the warrant shared by life
site reporter Patrick Delaney House
Arrest stems from an indictment on
charges of violating the freedom of
access to Clinic entrances act or the
face Act of 1994. specifically for
attacking a patient escort according to
his wife Hawk was providing sidewalk
counseling at abortion centers in
Philadelphia last year and had taken his
then 12 year old son on multiple
occasions over weeks a pro-abortion
protester allegedly shattered
vulgarities and insults of the boy how
repeatedly told the protester not to
speak to his son the protester continued
to encroach on the boy's personal space
uh still spewing vulgarities finally
Hulk shoved the man away causing him to
fall down
protester was not injured but tried to
sue Hulk though the case was thrown out
this summer it was somehow picked up by
the doj okay so that's
that's what led to this incident at the
house
uh and that was all it was you have a a
clinic this is a pro-abortion protester
I don't even know if it was like was it
a clinic escort or not not that it
matters
um
yeah it was it was a pro-abortion
protester who showed up
to counter you know the and and and for
how can
for most other pro-lifers who go to
abortion clinics and again if you've
ever been to one of these demonstrations
you know how most of them go it's
there's not shouting there's not
screaming usually it's just standing
there prayerfully and then there will be
sidewalk counselors who will try to
approach the women as they're going into
the abortion clinics and they're not
approaching them and screaming at them
they're not physically assaulting them
they're not verbally assaulting them
they're only trying to provide them with
information
because information is what they are not
given by the abortion clinic the
abortion clinic doesn't want them to
have any information at all so the
sidewall council is just trying to say
here would you like some information
about your baby about this procedure
that you're about to undergo what the
consequences are we'd like to give you
some information
abortion clinics will hire what they
call clinic escorts and their only job
is to get the women in the door
without encountering any of this
information they don't want the women to
get any information on the way in the
door it's it's to get them in the door
ignorant
to protect their ignorance as they walk
in the door
um and as we've talked about on the show
recently and the federal government
passed a law back in the 90s called the
freedom of access to Clinic entrances
act which or the face act which codifies
this which says that you know that the
pro that pro-lifers are not allowed to
get within within X number of feet of
the uh entrance to the abortion clinic
but that was not violated in this case
and that's why it was thrown out in
court and still the doj they got wind of
it and they decided they were going to
send some FBI goons to this guy's house
anyway
and while they're doing this just to
emphasize again while you have the FBI
sending 30 agents
to this guy's house
based on a minor incident that happened
a year ago where a guy got shoved and he
only got shoved because he was verbally
assaulting and harassing a child
so they could send 30 agents for that
and uh meanwhile uh
have there been have there been any
squadrons of FBI agents showing up at
anyone's house to to figure out you know
why these pro-life pregnancy centers are
getting attacked
because that's also included under the
face Act
it becomes a federal crime if you
damage
commit vandalism on a pro-life Pregnancy
Center
the FBI has done nothing about that
whatsoever
but they've got all the resources they
need I mean this is as many to give the
idea of how big a deal this was to them
this is as many as they sent to Bubba
Wallace's garage to look into a garage
to a suspicious garage door pull
all right one other thing White House
advisor Keisha Lance bottoms has some
thoughts about
um mega people as she calls them I.E
half the country let's listen to that
this election is a very important
election not just for Democrats but also
for Republicans also for Independence
and anyone who cares about the United
States of America there is a mega
Republican agenda that gives no
consideration to the rule of law that
has no respect for a woman's right to
choose that wants to defund the FBI
there is a Maga Republican agenda that
thought that it was okay to attack our
nation's capital on January 6. I think
people will think of all of these things
when they go to The Ballot Box no matter
what their party affiliation affiliation
is and and I think that they will vote
accordingly
you know I've noticed and I think a lot
of people have noticed a certain phrase
that you have been using since the very
first answer and that's Mega Republicans
or Mega Republican agenda it is a tough
line of taking being taken by the
president and by you here right now
against Republicans writ large my
question is will the president and will
folks in the administration in the
between now and the November 8th
elections keep hammering away at that at
that phrase at that imagery
well I think it will be important for
all of us who care about the United
States of America to call out what we
see and what we see again with this Mega
Republican agenda is an effort to
disrupt our democracy so whether it be
through November and Beyond November I
think it will always be important to
call out any effort there is to destroy
essentially destroy the United States of
America Thursday
so that's uh that's the Maga Republican
agenda and the reason I mean I she's
asked why they are they going to keep
Hammer it's a it's a tough line you're
taking against the mega Republicans yeah
that's one way of putting it a tough
line when you're demonizing half the
country and um it's impossible to
overstate just how unprecedented this
actually is to have the president the
White House uh
openly demonizing the voters now
there's there's nothing strange about
demonizing
your political opponents
elected officials
okay that happens on both sides
that's always happened
but to have the president going after
the voters too
and that's that's why they specify Maga
Republicans the Maga Republican agenda
Maga people Maga extremists whatever you
know whatever however they phrase it
the idea is to include not just the
elected Republicans but the people who
vote for them also
you know they want you to imagine a
trump rally and all Trump himself and
all the people in the in the stands
there with the hats on
all of them are
a threat
and Keisha Lance bottoms
well she's an advocate for the rule of
law she says that mag Republicans are
they oppose the rule of law
and she's also a Critic now of defunding
law enforcement
it's very interesting because here's
another fascinating thing to note about
Keisha land spots she was the mayor of
Atlanta up until very recently
so she was mayor when BLM burned her
City
she was mayor when a cop justifiably and
legally shot rayshard Brooks outside of
a Wendy's
when as you if you may recall Ray sharp
Brooks fell asleep because he was drunk
he was in the drive-through line at
Wendy's fell asleep drunk in his car
they called the police because what else
are they going to do police show up and
Brooks assaults the physically assaults
them and tries to steal their weapon
does steal it in fact and then gets shot
for his trouble
you could not have a more Justified
police shooting than that totally
justified and uh yet BLM went into
action
they showed up at the Wendy's where this
hap they burned the Wendy's down
just because this incident occurred in
the parking lot they figured let's burn
the Wendy's down
people in the community work there they
need the Wendy's for a job but who cares
let's burn it to the ground and also by
the way while they were burning the
Wendy's to a ground to the ground uh
they they shot and killed an
eight-year-old girl
whose only crime was she was in a car
that was driving by and they just fired
and shot the girl killed her
mayor Lance bottoms did nothing about
that at all I mean she did nothing to
protect her City she did nothing to stop
BLM
the city ended up getting sued by the
family of this of this poor girl and
rightfully so
because of the of the official
negligence that led up to this
so she does a horrible job as the mayor
of Atlanta she oversees the destruction
of her City and it's collapse it's
continued collapse into chaos
and then she's awarded with a job in the
White House
and now has repositioned herself
as an advocate of Law and Order
and she would actually dare to criticize
Republicans for wanting to supposedly
defund law enforcement she defunded the
police when she was mayor of Atlanta
now she she specified that well she
didn't she didn't really shy away from
calling it defunding but she did say
well we're gonna we're uh we're
reallocating resources away from law
enforcement to other things in other
words defunding the police
just totally utterly Shameless
but it's easy to act that way when you
have no soul basically
let's get to the comment section s
[Music]
Justin
pero I think I'm gonna say says 1.71
million subscribers this channel has
really been killing the game since Matt
did the documentary been here since the
show was him ranting in a car so cool to
see the channel grow exponentially since
then uh yeah we have uh the growth of
the channel has been pretty
extraordinary I have to say and we have
our audience the sweet baby gang to
thank for that but if you haven't
subscribed yet to the channel then you
should take this as
your opportunity to do so and also you
should be ashamed you have not done so
yet
let's see Corey Bernard says Matt you're
completely wrong about picky eaters I
was one when I was a kid and my mom
handled exactly the way you said well I
never ate the food I didn't like ever
even after years and my mom never gave
them either I ended up developing a very
low appetite as a result and became a
very underweight very underweight even
into my 30s just because of my low
appetite and when I say underweight I
literally mean a 15 on the BMI index and
constantly not being satisfied with my
food Growing Up made me eat only junk as
an adult all I wanted was Flavor
satisfaction not satiation I had to
relearn how to have an appetite and eat
good food again it wasn't until I was 32
that I finally had a normal body weight
it would have been better if my mom had
let me get full on something else rather
than force me to not eat the food I
didn't like
it forced me to have a bad relationship
with food that I struggle with I grew
out of my pickiness with food as most
kids will don't give them Eating
Disorders as a solution
well I
I have to say this so this just strikes
me as a
you say your mom
forced you to not eat the food you
didn't like I don't think your mom was
forcing that on you
and I still must insist again that you
like find an example of someone in a
third world country where the the like
can you I'd be curious
examples of picky eaters in third world
countries I think if you went to a third
world country and just even said the
phrase I'm a picky eater they would look
at you like it's they wouldn't
understand it what do you mean picky
eater what does that mean
so I still think that this is a first
world luxury and I would also say that
you might be an extreme case
because of your own stubbornness
although your mom I think handled it the
correct way
in in 95 percent of cases
if your kid is a picky eater
and you don't give in you don't you
don't start doing the thing or you make
them a separate meal don't let them eat
snacks that's another big thing because
they're always obsessed with eating
snacks during the day you got to keep
the snacks away from them and if you do
that then they'll get out of their picky
eating phase pretty quickly I we've done
this with our own kids four times
every kid goes through a phase where
they're where they are refusing to eat
dinner and it's it's relatively easy to
break them of that
I still maintain Melissa says Matt I
have to agree with those who say that
you're you're giving the right
quote unquote she puts it in quotes too
much credit for resisting gender
ideology Progressive feminists were
first to the battlefield on this [ __ ]
issue
and deserve more credit than you give
them this was again apparently a big
argument
um on Twitter over the weekend
how much how much credit should we give
feminists feminists aren't giving given
enough credit I'll say a couple things
about that
I think I've probably already said
enough
one point is that there is a difference
between the situation in the UK and the
situation here in the United States
and I think it is
quite apparent that left-wing feminists
in the UK
um have had
some success some some significant
success in pushing back
um against gender ideology
in terms of policy in terms of winning
the hearts and minds of the public you
know they've had success there
that's not the case in the USA now there
are maybe some you know there are some
left-wing feminists in this country who
are outspoken critics of gender ideology
but um almost all of the progress being
made in on this front is happening on
the right it just is in this country
and the other point too is that
if you're obsessed with getting credit
like if that's your if that's your your
uh your primary focus is making sure you
get all the credit that you want
then you're just going to be useless in
the fight
and this is my my problem even with the
feminists in the in the UK who again
have made some good Headway
in their country
on this issue
but then what is a woman comes out and
uh all all they can talk about is well
we didn't get enough credit we should
have been in this but why did we get
more credit
you take yourself out of the fight you
make yourself irrelevant
when you become obsessed with getting
credit
Adam says Matt I need you to chime in on
the great debate of Our Time Candy Corn
yay or nay yeah I know Knowles had a
trolling tweet over the weekend about
how much he loves candy corn I have to
assume it was trolling because nobody
actually really likes candy corn except
as a troll so obviously it's a it's a
nay it's a big nay for me on candy corn
candy corn tastes like
what they must have eaten for candy back
in the 17th century the pilgrims were
eating this stuff on the Mayflower this
is
you consider a treat if you are stuck on
a ship for months at Sea eating
bread filled with maggots and then if
someone gives in that case if someone
gives you some candy corn you would eat
it only that analogy doesn't quite work
either because candy corn also tastes it
tastes distinctly modern in the sense
that it tastes like a plastic by-product
it tastes artificial you know plastic it
tastes like a it tastes like a it should
have been made by Fisher Price
so I don't think anyone really likes
candy corn and you might be I think
maybe two or three times in my life I've
gone through there's been a moment
a moment of brief Insanity where I'm
weirdly in the mood for candy corn but
then you have one
and you snap out of it and you realize
how disgusting this stuff is
so that's the official rule in my candy
corn glad we could talk about that
you know what progressives will try to
do anything in their power to silence us
de-platforming Shadow Banning canceling
all the rest of it the great thing about
daily wire is no one can cancel us here
we uh not only speak our mind here every
day but we also go the extra mile to
interact with our audience too
I'm talking of course about all access
live our series of Q and A's that we do
every uh week every day and the exciting
news is that Jordan Peterson will be
hosting his very first all-access live
tomorrow September 27th at 1 pm Eastern
now you might remember Jordan has had an
appearance in my documentary what is a
woman if you don't remember you should
go back and re-watch it not just because
it's brilliant because
um that is the guy who might answer one
of your questions Jordan Peterson that's
right you'll get the chance to ask the
greatest thinker in western civilization
a burning question but only if you're a
daily wire plus all access member so if
you're not yet a member all you gotta do
is go to dailywire.com Walsh to
subscribe today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
by the name of Jordana Grace now as far
as I could tell based on the 35 seconds
of research I did in preparation for the
segment Jordana is an unmarried
childless woman in her 30s
um from the looks of it uh and no reason
to make fun of someone because of that
there are people who are unmarried and
childless in their 30s through no choice
of their own but if you're unmarried no
matter your age
the situation calls for some humility
there there is obviously quite a lot
about dating and relationships that you
don't understand yet because you haven't
made it to the next level so if you're
wise
and if you don't want to be single and
lonely for your entire life you'll
listen with an open mind to the insights
and advice of those who have made it
farther down the road than you
and you'll especially listen to the
voices of your ancestors who lived at a
time when most people managed to get
married much younger and they stayed
together much longer they stayed
together in fact in most cases until
death
because these were people who were bold
enough to take the marriage vows
seriously rather than treating them as
we do like a series of meaningless
bumper sticker slogans
but listening humbly does not appear to
be jordana's strong suit and so she has
made a series of viral Tick Tock videos
where she mocks 1950s dating advice I
believe she got this list from a
magazine article from 1958 and it's
absolutely hilarious she thinks let's
listen
ladies I found the handbook
[Laughter]
from 19
th it posted 129 ways to find a husband
here are the top tips number 17 be nice
to ugly men because handsome is as
handsome does
number 23 go to all your high school
reunions because it could be widowers
there
number 30 learn to paint and set up an
easel outside of an engineering school
number 25 go back to your hometown
because the Wild Boy make because the
Wild Boy Next Door might now be an as
usual Bachelor number 33 carry a hat box
number 38 drop a handkerchief it still
works
[Music]
beautiful or a Band-Aid so we can all
you can ask number 40 is the best stand
in a corner and cry softly because I'll
come over and hot spots wrong
let me just add one more tip right from
the outset um do not cackle
condescendingly like some kind of smarmy
hyena
ladies I'm telling you that there is
nothing less attractive to a man than
fake pompous
shrieking patronizing laughter
now men are famously visually oriented
if you're if you are if you are
physically attractive it is relatively
difficult to lose attractiveness points
in our eyes but condescension in general
and especially condescension in the form
of an annoying laugh that'll do it it
causes within us a reaction of of actual
physical revulsion
so just don't do it it's not worth it we
love your warm genuine laughter we hate
the fake disdainful I'm better than you
left so keep that one bottle up bottled
up if you can but what about this advice
from 1958
uh Jordana finds it hysterical now she
hasn't found us out her found a husband
herself yet but she's quite sure that
these tricks of the trade are laughably
absurd and I admit that through a modern
lens
some of them do seem kind of funny but
let's drop that modern Prejudice for a
moment and take a look at them again
so first it says be nice to ugly men now
as an ugly man myself I may be biased
but this seems like worthwhile advice to
me in fact you should be nice to
everyone as a default until they give
you a good reason to act well otherwise
because men are attracted to nice women
I might maybe that's like breaking news
these days but it's true
as previously covered there is no
personality trait in a woman that we
find less attractive than rudeness and
condescension
despite all the modern propaganda
telling women to be tough hard-edged
girl bosses quote unquote the fact is
that men still prefer women who are kind
and empathetic and warm and feminine
also on the subject of ugly men in
particular it's worth keeping in mind
that men will often hit their Peak
physically mentally financially later in
life so from a woman's perspective a man
might be at his most desirable in his
30s 40s even 50s there has been many a
man written off as ugly and undesirable
in young adulthood who later checks
every box so that seems to be part of
what this piece of advice is hinting at
um and I think this also mostly explains
explains the advice about going to high
school reunions and returning to your
hometown though both of those are
perhaps Irrelevant in modern times
because many adults never leave their
hometowns and social media has made High
School reunions mostly obsolete I guess
you don't need to go to the reunion to
see who got rich and who got fat you
know Facebook for that what about the
advice urging single women to uh set up
easels outside of an engineering school
now
I'm not sure that I would
choose an engineering school necessarily
as Engineers tend to be sort of weird
but the general strategy is quite
ingenious because men are attracted to
women with artistic talents that we we
like that we you know we don't much care
about the money you make or how far
you've climbed on the corporate ladder
but we do find artistic talent
interesting and this certainly works in
the reverse too probably more so
the fact is that whether you're a man or
a woman you'll be seen as more beautiful
if you can create beautiful things
and talent whether artistic talent or
any other kind of talent is attractive
in general to everybody
the rest of the advice all falls into
the same category you know wear a
Band-Aid cry in a corner
carry a hat box
you might even try doing all these
things at once now I can't
personally endorse the strategy because
it's a little bit too dishonest and
manipulative for my taste but I can't
deny the potential effectiveness of it
of it either
see the point is to ignite a man's
chivalrous side
give him a reason to help you
I assume the idea behind the hat box is
that you know man might offer to carry
it for you and a hat box is I I don't
know if I've ever seen a hat box but I
guess it's like pretty big and kind of
cumbersome but it's light
so that makes it easy like a man can
offer to help it for you but it's not
gonna be too heavy for him and he can
feel like he's doing something
now I would perhaps update this to a
more relevant object for the Modern Age
though a hat box would have the
advantage of being an interesting
conversation starter it would give a man
a chance to ask questions like why did
you buy this large hat why are you
carrying it around in a box rather than
on your head where are you going with
the hat
what will you do with it when you get
there
many successful relationships have begun
with hat related conversations of this
sort
now as for standing in the corner and
crying or faking a physical injury
these are tactics as old as time itself
men want to be able to help they want to
use their masculine energy in that way
there's a reason why the storybooks
Through the Ages have always told of men
rescuing damsels in distress a man wants
to be a hero
and if you can give a man that
opportunity hopefully in a less
deceitful way it will benefit both you
and him
the point is to encourage those nobler
more chivalrous impulses
and if such strategies are less reliable
in modern times it's only because men
have been increasingly conditioned to
suppress those masculine impulses
on the basis that chivalry is toxic and
patriarchal now so it may be true that
in some places in our country today blue
States mostly a woman could cry in the
corner and no man will come to her to
her aid but if that's the case it's an
indictment on our culture not on the
culture that produced the dating advice
that this woman is mocking
and whatever you think of the advice
it is certainly better than the than the
list of advice that our culture would
come up with
so think about a modern list of dating
tips for women would sound something
like this
number one uh totally neglect your
physical appearance fat is beautiful
body positivity means destroying your
body on purpose you go girl
number two swear off having children
make sure every every man knows that if
he ends up with you his bloodline will
die with him men just they love that
not going to leave a legacy behind that
they they can't get enough of that
number three family life is oppressive
and archaic so divorce devote yourself
fully to uh your employer instead
men are sexually attracted to ambitious
career-minded women most of all that's
what they want the most
number four the more bitter and
disdainful you are the better and then
finally
um number five you don't need no man so
make sure men know that you don't need
them
men love to not be needed
the more useless you make a man feel uh
the more attracted to you he will be
that's that's the modern list
and it's a list that would Garner full
approval on tick tock among women who
have never been in a successful romantic
relationship and probably never will be
because they literally laugh at wisdom
in the words of scripture professing
themselves to be wise
they become fools
which is why in the much less eloquent
words of the Matt Walsh show
they are canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]